salut à tous c'est pêcheurs de trésor
aujourd'hui pour changer on est au bord
de l'eau au bord du canal ouais ça
change beau petit canal avec un très
vieux P ouais ça a l'air bien sympa et
ce qu'on va faire c'est bien sûr pour
changer aussi pêcherément bah oui on va
visiter le canal quoi c'est ça on est en
compagnie de jade de Rasta de Sydney et
on va tous jeter nos aimants en même
temps alors celui qui a la meilleure
découverte il va payer quoi laapéro le
café le café le café le café allez ça va
on prend pas trop de risque attention 1
3 déjà si si on chope des choses direct
ah
ouais ah c'est pas fait c'est sûr c'est
peut-être un coup de chance ah non
c'estin
c'est ah
ouais allez-y régaleznous qu'est-ce que
tu nous sors jade du la barre de fer
imagine c'est un canon ok ça commence
timidement pour
Jade capsule c'est pas mal barre de fer
et capsule Quentin
ok barre de fer aussi c'est pas fait
ouais c'est pas fait mais barre de fer
et ouais bah ouais rien de ouf mais
allez on ah ouais vous avez raison il y
a plein de choses plein de
Ch
ah bon ben je pense que personne ne va
payer le café non non on va juste
relancer les aimants et et ça va être
très bien comme ça on a de la marge il à
faire regardez ça va jusqu'à là-bas il
un autre pont ici beaucoup de vieux
objets je pense ou parce qu'il y a pas
de délinquence récente ouais donc
qu'est-ce que c'est le la meilleure
découverte qu'on peut nous souhaiter à
mon avis ouais des armes de résistant
peut-être ça peut être
sympa ch on sent des choses sont bien
dans la vase quand même c'est quoi que
tu as jade un bijou je sais pas trop
alors alors
alors il y a un truc à l'intérieur avec
une croix Mo c'est un truc ouais alors
c'était un porte-clé mais effectivement
dedans un château non une photo avec un
château ben ça y ressemble parce que là
tu vois ça fait une croix h ça ressemble
à un ce truc de des églises qu'il y a là
ça tourne mais c'est qu'il est peu c'est
pas normal ouais ok mais bien bien bien
je connais pas du tout très sympa bien
joué jade
OK
qu'est-ce que c'est ça une énorme pile
ou bonne dépollution comme dirait
Quentin un
couteau pas ou mais c'est pas mal Opinel
quand
même c'est de la
marque tu vois qu'il est bien conservé
c'est de la qualité une grosse pile
bravo
bpution
me qui vousonnu ah
sais l'URE de
pêche ok il est devenu noir mais il
marche encore je
pense c'est des vux
ça vous arrêtez de ruiner les vux des
gens j'ai failli me claquer le Doig ça a
été filmé c'est dangereux
ça en tout cas on a une belle vue de ce
pont oh une pile encore une diracelle
belle dépolution ah ça pique
ok ça c'est l'élément
rempli oh un porte-monnaie et il est
super ancien waouh il y aura des Francs
alors ah ben franchement le
porte-monnaie il a 100 ans on dirait
c'est j'ai le même c'est les petites
foufounes ah il y a quelque chose dedans
oh
non jure
jure
venez j'arrive j'arrive j'arrive je il
est rempli de
bijoux oh non
j'adore
wou
montit montre-moi il est rempli de
bijoux rempli il était plein de
bijoux ça a pas l'air trop abîmé ça
l'air en bon état regarde pour le temps
que ça fait dans l'eau on dirait de
l'or mais oui parce que l'or ça ça
devient rose qu et regarde même celui-là
elle est en bon état parce que regarde
la tête du porte-monnaie et les trucs
avec mais non regarde bon ça c'est ça
c'est un pin si tu as raison et
franchement je sais pas faudra regarder
mais regarde ça deuxième oh mais ça
c'est des trucs de manchette
ça c'est pas en toc hein une médaille
c'est pas en toc hein saint Rita
protégez-nous toujours protégez-moi
toujours saint trita ça c'est religieux
un petit icon mais c'est la Vierge Marie
et du coup c'est bien conservé là et un
petit ouais ouais mais regarde ils sont
super bien conservés quand tu regardes
quand tu regardes l'état de celui-là il
y a de l'ORS ou c'est Plaquet mais je je
me pose des questions les
gars un ensemble parce que regarde
dansour dans la Bour
j j'avoue que tu et là regarde en fait
c'est que c'est un ensemble tuasas un
petit pin là ouais et ça va avec la
pince à cravate pour payer le café bah
pour l'instantou et même le
porte-monnaie est très joli alors on va
laisser tout dedans et on est il est
sympa aussi ça commence bien peut-être
écrit quelque chose dessus regarde vous
faut bien écaper ouais et là on a
quelque chose de super bizarre surtout
super
lourd ça ti un de cul ah ouais il y a un
gros grillage là ah mais c'est un piège
ouais c'est pour les poissons ça non
ouais c'est un piège il va me falloir un
deuxième aent je pense j'arve j'arrive
j'arrive je me dépêche tiens bon tiens
bon tiens bon
j'attends alors on essay carrément
dessous je
pense ça se prend ouais ça se prend de
c'est que là il va commencer à être plus
lourd attendsou
attends je sais pas s'il va êtreenté par
en
dessous c'est quoi vous avez trouvé là
ça pi à poisson ouais faudrait un
troisème ément je pense Quentin oh mais
il y a un gros sachet en dessous ah
c'est lourd ah oui je le sens c'est
ouais il y a quand même un gros sachet
qutin peut-être un trè fait en vrai ça
peut être intéressant à sortir et à
fouiller ah attends c'est une couette
non une couette ouais on dirait un plus
un sac en toile de jute
je crois que c'est super lourd parce que
c'est une couette gorgé d'eauattant que
c'est pas des animaux de d je m'en fous
non on dirait pas du coup là je pleure
moi je pleure
bonjour non c'est pas aenté le plastique
ça ouais de le tu chopes plutôt un
nosément pour qu'on soit sûr de bloquer
le truc entre je pense ah genre c'est
pas le mien je sais
pas Essie de tuasu ce truc là un
ah tomber essayer ça c'est ton étend
Rall
Ste de sac sur merci pour l'étendir
ouis ah le grillage aussi retomberé oua
ah mince ouais ça va être compliqué de
le retrouver à part le coincer entre nos
deux aimants sans faire exprès mais ah
si si mais un truc est mé peut-être
parce qu'il se soulève un peu quand
même
ah c'est un miroir non ça ou une horloge
ou une horloge un plateau juste un
plateau c'est une horloge ah ouais c'est
troué au milieu une horloge h ok bon ben
sympa un bon
Frisbey ah j'allais le tester mais a une
voiture il y a beaucoup de capsules
aussi je sais pas c'est franchement je
sais pas ce que c'est ce sac mais c'est
bizarre continue à travailler il est
juste là et à chaque fois que je passe
là-dessus c'est rempli c'est très
bizarre on va essayer de coincer nos
aments entre les deux cordes ah non
c'est pas le pied
c'est alors le le sac il est là au
milieu je sais pas si vous le voyez à
l'écran un ciseau ah bravo bien joué ne
en plus ma pède ou même
pas non tu crois que c'est ok pour
couper les orteils de Quentin ou
pas vas
ouais c'est bon ce sera bon pour les
ongles de Quentin c'est trop bizarre ah
on a perdu le lustre mais au moins on
sort la couette que peut-être est encore
accroché le poid que ça fait il est
encore
accroché qu'est-ce que c'est ce machin
c'est hyper lourd
c'est accroché
non c'est qui
ça ça s de pas te
tremper oh qu'est-ce que c'est que ça
ouais tu veux un lustre mais c'est pour
chez toi Quentin il y a aucun lustre
ça c'est une perruque avec des avec des
cheveux roses d'Halloween c'est un
déguisement
d'Halloween on
dirait on a un joli lustre oh là là mais
sérieusement le lustre ça avit rien à
voir avec la qu je pense ouis je pense
qu' c'est juste ouais l'utilité de jeter
ça dans l'eau
je sais pas
mais mais c'est des trucs super c'est un
beau lustre en il est sympa
dommage lustre pasentable du coup en
plus il ira très bien chez Quentin parce
que il a il a aucun lustre ça c'est du
vert tu vois ok cool j'ai quelque chose
de bleu
là ah mais oui je connais
[Musique]
ça comment ça s'ouvre déjà ah c'est
rigolo c'est un jouet mais il semble qu'
avait une manip du style
vasy pas ça ça svre j'arrive à
l'ouvrir all dans du
chien comment
commentouvre j fa ici c'était
d'ut vousz vous avez déjà vu du monde
ici ok
d'accord j'imine il reste encore un peu
mais ça se voit ça été nettoyé j'ai
trouvé un
pochon un
pochoné qu'est-ce que c'est
ça
une clé avec tu vol c'est une
vis un bout de visseuse là de
vuse il est
préservé bon ok
cool il est fosstilisé attends ah non
non non je suis sûr non vous êtes sûr ah
c'est il serait pas tordu comme ça ça
ressemble et s'il est vieux ah si de ouf
oh j'ai trop cru qu'est-ce que c'est il
est mou jouet attends c'est pas un jouet
ah mais il tombe en mi regarde il se
casse est-ce que c'est creu bah vas-y en
vrai casseele au point il en est je
pense oh ça me fait chier si çaen est
vraiment un non mais pour voir si c'est
creux dans le canon forme regarde comme
ça regarde c'est pas creu c'est ah si
c'est creux il y a c'est creu à
l'intérieur il y a une c'est bizarre il
y a une tige ah ça me fait chier de
faire ça mais ouais attends ah si ça si
ça
fait comme un mais pourquoi il serait
tordu remontre si les vieux et que mais
dis pas que c'est un jouet laisse-moi il
est
bizarre attends le casse pas ma faus
arm si vous avez une idée en commentaire
c'est vrai que c'est bizarre bien joué
jaade ah qu'est-ce que c'est ce truc
bleu là oh ta crayon
sal
ah il est pas vieux ouis Mo il est
peut-être
utilisable le tombe pas ou là là
qu'est-ce qu'il fait qu'est-ce qu'il
fait des acrobaties bonne journée merci
bonne journée es prê
ID oh
elle comprendra pas
attention je vous souhaite de pou merci
merci beaucoup
ouaisp parce que vous devrez être payé
B Merci à VOUS bonne journée merci
beaucoup en tout cas bonne journée au
revoir bon ben je sais pas ce que c'est
çatin tu en penses quoi euh je sais pas
un genre de
pouli morceau de pouli bon là les gars
je peux pas vous aider hein allez on a
quelque
chose oh là là c'est rempli oh là là une
cagette pour ramasser la ferraille la
c'est parfait allez hop je vais pouvoir
commencer à la remplir du coup allez
j'ai quelque chose oh
ouais oh une montre une montree j'ai une
montre
ouais c'est nul ton cerclage
elle a pris l'eau par contre Spirit
Saint-Louis enfin je fais une belle
trouvaille
là je suis pas sûr que ce soit une
grosse qualité et ça c'est une cuillère
plaqug
je reconnais oui tu as la même chez toi
ouais regarde ça te plaît ouais merci on
vous reprend on a changé de pont c'est
le trème pont de la journée on a même
pas filmé le deuxième parce qu'il était
super propre ah Quentin a trouvé quelque
chose au milieu du
pont ou là ça ça bouge
mais il y a plein de bulles là c'est un
gros truc et je sais pas ça il est
peut-être coincé sur un rocher ouais
peut-être tu vois ça fait bizarre ah oui
ça buûle bien ah ben ça vient oui ça
vient c'est très lourd ah bah oui ça
vient coup deain moto pour l'instant ça
va mais c'est lourd c'est très lourd
ouais là il s
tankqué toiuss ouais viens allez tuas
qu'à faire pas mal les bulles
intéressant et comme quoi tu vois on
était parti pessimiste ouais ouais déjà
fa ben là ça par assz m ben peut-être de
la mobyette ou un truc comme ça he ah
mais toujour pas d'huile he ça veut rien
dire ah ça ri ouais on a besoin des gros
muscles ouais j'ai des gros bras tu vas
derrière allez girl power
allez 1 2 3 ah ça a lâché dommage j'ai
quand même un bout je
crois aïe pas bon si ouais mais bon sait
jamais
ok bon si c'était magnétique tant mieux
moi aussi j'ai peut-être quelque chose
on va remonter oh
oh
non quel échec ah ben ouais des choses
ouais les choses dont je me serais bien
passé ah bon je vous reprends dans 45
minutes quand j'ai nettoyé cet aiment
quelque chose pendant que jeis en train
de nettoyer mes clou
oh bien joué du calibre 12 avec des
algues ouais beaucoup d'algues et ouais
ça c'est une seule munition c'est une
sorte de Slog c'est bien ouais c'est
vachement grand ouais c'est long et à la
fin ça ça ou on me le dit tout le temps
ça arrête c'est un peu plus gros
qu'est-ce qu'il m'a dit lui aussi qu pas
ça VI tu m'as volé mon objet alors j'ai
volé ton objet je vais le remonter seul
finalement parce que il était pas si
lourd c un peu exagéré mais qu'est-ce
que ça peut être franchement je sais pas
du tout ce que ça peut être ah ben oui
oh c'est un panneau élégant c'est lourd
parce
que Oh sortie de camion ah non mais
c'est sortie d'engin Mo que je veux oui
vous voulez sorti d'engin pour les
toilettes oui ah vous voulez le sorti
d'engin non non tant pis faut continuer
la pue prochaine fois ouais si comme
nous vous souhaitez pratiquer la pêche à
l'ément faut savoir que les notes
proviennent du site de maison de la
détection on utilise les Barbarian donc
c'est les plus puissants c'est 1600 kg
mais vous avez différentes gammes sur le
site toutes les infos sont en
description de la vidéo et vous avez
aussi le code promo pêcheur de trésor
qui offre au moins 5 % sur toute la
boutique hop on a un joli leure de pêche
bon ça c'est classique hein pour les
coins même quand ils sont même quand les
coins sont propres en général on
toujours en faire un ou deux ils sont
ils sont très peu aentés mais avec les
les plus puissants on y arrive pas vrai
mon petit
Quentin du PO j'ai peur ah pas que pas
que maniv d'écluse ah génial tu es sûr
ouais c'est une manivelle ça si c'est
une manivelle de une
VAN une manivan une manivan elle est
belle pas mal pas
mal
pourou
plein de clous aussi ouais pas que non
ouais il y en a un qui paraît un peu
grand al insta on est en vidéo là ah
c'est un burin euh oui c'est ça un petit
coin un coin un coin ouais un coin pour
ah oui est il est ancien en plus ouais
mais il est petit en tout cas on se dit
à la semaine prochaine pour une nouvelle
vidéo de pêche
àéement bon on a essayer de nettoyer au
mieux les bijoux mais dans tous les cas
on peut voir que d'après les poinons ce
n'est pas de l'or malheureusement c'est
du Plaquet on VO ils sont assez abîmés
mais ça reste quand même très
sympa